6 34 developing this morning three weeks
ago the clark county school board fired
superintendent dr jesus jarrah they gave
no reason they didn't have to but early
this morning trustees changed their mind
boy and it was a heated meeting dr
jarrah not there and this morning we
don't know whether he actually does in
fact want to stay here with clark county
school district hector mahia joining us
now live near flamingo in mcleod where
that meeting was and boy hector lots to
digest here
more than seven hours of discussion in
fact several items were on the agenda
the school board eventually voted to
keep dr jara as superintendent as the
school board tries to fix what appears
to be a huge mess here and here's what
we saw board members kept their cool for
the most part but outbursts were
inevitable between trustees they voted
for three changing their decision from
three weeks ago to fire dr jesus jar as
ccsd superintendent however the district
is aware there's a possibility he will
not accept the board also voted to
reconsider the termination for
convenience meaning they did not have to
provide a reason at the time and hear
this last night we also learned the
board did not even have a transition
plan in place
all i want is a proper plan a proper
proper plan to transition have a year
where we actually have student outcomes
we have not done one of those this year
not one single one
stop you are a phony baloney
that's what i said to your face funny
you know
this is uh
trustee ford
trustee morales
so we saw those exchanges a few of those
between trustees on public display
jarrah's contract was not the only major
topic last night though they postponed a
decision on a possible interim
superintendent in case jarrah does leave
the board also approved to bring in an
outside expert to start looking into
allegations of a hostile work
environment and this vote comes after dr
jarrah's attorney sent the district a
letter accusing the board of bullying
and retaliation his attorneys are
demanding the district to pay up a
settlement of two million dollars
reporting live hector mejia live local
now